[Music]
it says the leopard-like beast makes war
with the saints
for the two months as for revelation
chapter 13 verse 5
when in history do we see this fulfilled
and what are the ways bees the beast
rather blasphemes god and god's name
tabernacle and heavenly host so it's
like a two week question the first part
is
what are the ways that the bees black
beam
when did the production begin that's the
first part i think then the second part
is how does it last
persecution of the church
began long before fight before
the
free
persecution of god
but when the
decree
the head
of the church officially made him the
head of the universal church
the period between
and yet
we recorded a time when persecution of
god's people continues more intense than
others it was never at the same level of
intensity all through the period but up
and down but in that period 538 to 79
years was when persecution raged back
and forth against the church of god as i
said to varying levels of severity from
538 but before that the church was
persecuted in the days of the apostles
the church was persecuted and any
persecuting power of the church is an
agent of the devil the bible tells us
clearly the spirit of antichrist was
working in the dead of the apostle
that's one of the messages of
first john and also ii john the spirit
of antichrist was at work long before
the papacy was established it just
continued on in a glo in a you know on a
wider scale and in a more organized way
but persecution according to prophecy
began
extending from 538 bc not bc 80 to 1798
the 1260 year period when the the dragon
working through his age the beast the
leopard-like beast harassed
the church of god harassment goes on now
but differently
now how did the beast uh
lasted in the name of god
by claiming to forgive sins now in the
end
in the catholic system you cannot be
forgiven by going directly to god
you cannot
but god is not directly accessible to
you you've got through christ but to get
the christ you've got to go to the
priest you've got to go to the
sacraments you cannot go straight to god
and so the priest stands between you and
god or the system you the system takes
the place of god you see the mediator is
christ but in the church's system the
media is the priest and the sacraments
the the sacramental system of that
church and so it stands in the place of
god you cannot go directly to god the
priest himself not only hears your
confession the priest can forgive your
sins only god can do that mark chapter 2
verse 5 to 7 who only who but god can
forgive sins also the pope is the
representative of god on earth he takes
the place of god on earth he is in a
very practical sense the visible
representation of god on earth this is
blasphemy when jesus said he was the son
of god meaning he was equal with god the
jews tried to kill him because they
understood calling himself god and no
human being who's only human can claim
to be god and so in these two ways
principally there may be other ways but
principally these two ways claiming to
forgive since only god can do that and
taking the place of god on earth
standing between the sin of god
only christ can do that those are two
blasphemous expressions of that system
so the blessed name of god and his
temple and them that dwell in heaven
amen
all right you touch a little on the top
of an apple and also on the heavenly
host how does um how does the beast
blaspheme the heavenly host in general
the heavenly host
can refer to god's people on earth
the heavenly hosts can refer to the
angels
now the beast cannot reach the angels
the beast can reach us you see
and so
we have
in heaven according to that system
a core edema
uh what is called a redemptrix the
female version of redeemer that is mary
we have in the heavenly system according
to that system the saints who died and
now we're in heaven and you can pray to
them and so that is a form of blessing
the heavenly host but we as children of
god you see we are members of the
kingdom of god the kingdom of heaven is
upon you the kingdom of god is within
you we are
also spiritually part of the heavenly
host and he blasphemes god's people
through the deception that he tries to
perpetrate upon them
he blessed christ by trying to take his
place
he blessing god the father by being the
holy father on earth
thank you very much
you